the countdown is on for a space mission
that promises to put human beings back
on the moon
final preparations are being made for
the launch of nasa's heavy duty space
launch system or sls and orion space
capsule for a month-long mission to
orbit the moon despite bad weather and
even a lightning strike on saturday
officials say the mission is set to
blast off on monday bottom line is we
look really good no issues no concerns
or constraints from the lightning events
at this point the unmanned mission marks
the debut of nasa's artemis program
which seeks to return american
astronauts to the moon by the year 2025.
the sls is the most powerful rocket nasa
has ever assembled capable of producing
nearly 4 million kilograms of thrust a
significant upgrade from the saturn 5
rockets that sent the first men to the
moon in the days of the apollo program
going forward to the moon is the right
way to describe it because it's not your
grandfather's apollo program okay this
is all new technology
new motivation new opportunity bringing
all that technology to the moon is going
to be exciting
years overdue and billions over budget
the moment is almost here for launch of
artemis one with more than a hundred
thousand people expected to attend all
of them collectively holding their
breath crossing their fingers for a
successful liftoff the excitement from
spectators at cape canaveral is palpable
just going back to the moon it's pretty
cool i
didn't get to experience the first one
that i remember so
i get to sew my son and hopefully watch
the next few and see them walk back on
the moon
it's been 50 years since the last person
stepped foot on the moon through artemis
nasa hopes to set the foundations for
deep space exploration and one day send
human beings to mars and worlds beyond
manuel rapalo al jazeera kennedy space
center florida